[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so we didn't get the results
that we wanted in North Carolina's ninth
district this is the district where this
goes back to November of 2018 I mean
it's been almost a year since this all
started in November of 2018
North Carolina's ninth district was so
riddled with electioneering from
Republican operatives potentially
illegal collection of absentee ballots
being filled in and signed by associates
of Republican activists the long and
short of it which we covered a whole
bunch between since then and up until a
couple of months ago was that a
completely new election needed to be
done and what we learned was that even
though the Democratic Calot candidate
from November of 2018 Dan McReady was
going to run again the Republican
candidate was not running again and
instead a guy named Dan Bishop ended up
running and we thought we really had a
shot here either way Democrats took over
control of the house in November of 2018
and regardless of the results of this
special election Democrats were going to
keep it but we thought we had a shot at
getting one more in the house for the
majority and it didn't work out that way
it was very very narrow but Dan Bishop
won 51 to 49 on Tuesday evening over the
Democrat Dan McReady this is not good
news in terms of the electoral result
but there's an interesting perspective
which is that this is actually not quite
so good for Trump nor for Republicans
one perspective is that when you look at
how close it was despite the fact that
Donald Trump carried these districts in
2016 that this does not bode well for
Donald Trump in North Carolina in the
November of 2020 election which is
another data point but quite frankly Pat
I mean we're seeing this already in
polling more broadly in North Carolina
and in Texas and in other states so it's
great to have an additional data point
that supports that but ultimately we
don't really know whether this is
actually bad for Trump and we're not
going to know until we actually get into
in November of 2020 election so you know
the term Pyrrhic victory which is when
you win yes but you there's so many so
much loss in the making of that win that
it feels like a loss overall I feel like
this is the opposite where this is
technically a loss we didn't get that
that extra congressional seat but it
looks like signs are pointing in the
direction of some good news coming in
2020 because Trump carried the district
by 12 points and Republican the
Republican candidate here only won it by
2 this time so that's some good progress
this also seems kind of emblematic of
the the 2018 midterm elections overall
because there certainly was a blue wave
but it didn't feel like it so much at
the time like after election night we
thought we would pick up about 25 to 30
seats I think it turned out to be more
like 40 but initially we were thinking
like well Andrew Gilliam lost in Florida
Stacey Abrams lost in Georgia
Rita O'Rourke lost in Texas Democrats
didn't take the Senate I mean was this
really all that good of a night for us
so I think this is kind of the same
thing where the signs are pointing in
the right direction we're you know
having all this progress but it's just
not showing up in the results I think it
will though come 20/20 I think that
things are moving in the right direction
there is something particularly you know
you mentioned a Pyrrhic victory there is
something particularly disappointing
about we the election in November of
2018 was riddled with problems and it
was riddled with problems to such a
degree that an entire new election was
called for the Republicans said I'm not
even going to be running and trying to
win the seat anymore it seems like wow
Republicans cheated the Republican
candidates not even running again the
Democratic candidate is running again
like it we've got it we've got it
and then some other Republican who is a
state senator and had name recognition
locally ends up winning like I think
part of it like this doesn't as you're
pointing out this doesn't change the
broader reality of the Democratic
majority and of the outlook for 2020 but
it feels particularly disappointing
because it seemed like we just should
have been able to grab this one yeah and
it's just one congressional seat out of
435 so that alone isn't so important but
I think this kind of could have served
as a bellwether
if Democrats had picked up a seat here
would be a really bad sign for Trump
interestingly enough - a few days before
the election Trump had a rally in the
district and with no sense of irony he
was talking about how voters should
watch out for voter fraud of course
about people voting twice right people
you know who may not be registered in
the district voting in the district dead
people the whole reason you had this
election in the first place was because
of election fraud perpetrated by
Republicans and Republican allies and
just no sense of irony that was
completely lost now the guy is unable to
understand irony and he has no sense of
shame and this is what you get him
ignoring ignorant to the fact or
ignoring the fact that the entire reason
he's even down there campaigning for
someone is because his party perpetrated
such terrible voter fraud that there's a
new election and he says watch out for
voter fraud of course implying that it's
Democrats no sense of shame no sense of
irony and I think the same could apply
to this next story which relates to the
classification of employees the
classification of workers as either
employees or independent contractors
this is a big deal
here the David Pakman show everybody is
an employee okay and there is definitely
a gray area in which many small
businesses operate where in order to
save money you classify people who are
working for you as independent
contractors rather than employees and
there is a test that the IRS applies to
determine whether someone should be
classified as an employee or an
independent contractor part of it has to
do whether with whether the person is
setting their own schedule or you are
determining the schedule on which they
work part of it depends on whether they
are doing similar work for other
companies or whether they are only doing
this work for you there's a bunch of
different tests that apply and one of
the big battles that uber and lyft have
been fighting is this battle over
whether their drivers are independent
contractors or really whether they
should be classified as employees and of
course being classified as employees
creates more of a responsibility to them
by uber and lyft and of course uber and
lyft have been fighting it tooth and
nail because they want to save money
it's cheaper for them
for drivers to be independent
contractors now California has passed a
bill which potentially would mandate
that gig economy workers like uber and
lyft drivers be reclassified as
employees instead of contractors the
governor is supporting it
uber is saying that it doesn't apply to
its business arguing that drivers aren't
part of its usual course usual course of
business which sounds crazy when you
think about what uber is in a practical
sense is a service for drivers to come
and pick you up and bring you places
without the drivers there is no business
and uber is doing something which listen
it's clever from it from a legal
perspective which is they are saying
hold on a second the usual course of
uber x' business like ubers real core
business is they are a technology
company with an app that facilitates
rides but the driving piece itself is
not really part of what uber does uber
is a technology company it's a human
resources company whatever and the
drivers are just out on the street
they're driving around on the street
they're not part of what uber is doing
which is people sitting in offices
making an app and providing tech support
this is legally extremely clever Pat and
at the same time completely ridiculous
in every sense yeah I think it strikes
me that drivers are fundamental to the
business model of uber and lyft I think
that's pretty clear and also you know
you're talking about the distinction
between what makes an independent
contractor versus an employee and one of
those things is that maybe you can't
work for multiple companies at a time
certainly within the same industry if
you're an employee well lift doesn't
allow drivers to work for other
ride-hailing services so that would
suggest to me that those drivers should
be classified as employees not
independent contractors but that's the
one thing young I didn't know that lyft
had that provision but every time I get
into a lyft or an uber they always seem
to have two phones one logged in to lift
and one logged in to Ebor everybody
seems to be working for both yet I
always see on the
she that uber you and you have the lift
logo you know maybe they're doing
something wrong there but I won't get
into their business and I'll okay so but
maybe like to provide a counter-argument
to like steel man the opposition here
yes with uber and lyft you can choose
your own hours you don't have to work a
twenty hour work week a thirty hour work
week a forty hour work week sure you can
choose when you're gonna start being on
the clock and when you're going to stop
that's that's not at all like a normal
you know employee job right where you
have to be there nine to five Monday
through Friday so maybe that is one of
the arguments in favor of these drivers
being independent contractors instead of
employees maybe there's one no question
that we can both come up with some ways
in which the case is strengthened I mean
that the fact that the employees
determine the employees the drivers
determine their own hours that they're
using their own vehicle that at least
maybe from the perspective of uber
they're also allowed to work for lyft
but at the same time a lot of them
aren't in that situation so I'll give an
example I believe both uber and lyft
have programs where if you don't have or
want to use your own vehicle you can
Oberer lyft will provide you one and I
believe that there is some fear take a
higher percentage of your rides or
there's a certain amount that goes
towards paying for the car each month
when you have one of their vehicles you
are often required to work a certain
number of hours or heavily incentivize
to work particular hours or whatever the
case may be and there a lot of the
strongest arguments that uber and lyft
might have for why these are independent
contractors and not employees start to
fall apart very quickly now I know that
I'm talking now only of the people that
are using one of burrower lifts cars but
for a huge percentage of the people
particularly when you look at how uber
and lyft incentivize drivers to be
working particular hours that they've
determined or convenient for them I I
think that very clearly these should be
employees that's the right thing to do
yeah and I think California is moving in
the right direction here I hope it does
get signed into law also because I think
that you as the government should be
able to have the sort of influence on
companies especially ones that use your
infrastructure uber and lyft
sir all are using the Rose and the you
know pulling up next to the sidewalks of
stuff that we all pay for and so if you
want to ask for like the most basic
things like to provide their workers
with sick leave with paid leave time off
benefits like you should be able to do
that I think and I think that this will
end up happening we will see how it goes
down and and the California cases of
particular importance because California
being such a large state population wise
it would be extremely impactful if this
sticks there in terms of how uber and
lyft may be forced to operate in other
states as well so we'll be following it
and this is a this is just like a
fundamental workers rights thing in my
view we talked last week and a little
bit this week about sharpy gate and
Alabama as a place that Donald Trump
claimed Hurricane Dorian was bearing
down on even though weather services
said that it was not and we've gotten
you know in the end I feel like the
truth does come out and it's always
pretty predictable we learned over the
last 10 days or so that weather
forecasters were saying that Alabama was
not at risk of being hit by Hurricane
Dorian Donald Trump was saying that it
was and we in the interim learned that
NOAA the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration was told they
should not be contradicting what Donald
Trump said about Alabama even if
individual meteorologists are
contradicting it and we wondered who was
involved in this was the White House
involved in this was at Wilbur Ross who
seems to always be involved in horrible
things as Trump's commerce secretary and
just generic evil super rich guy and now
we are learning that indeed Wilbur Ross
was at the center of this and he was
involved in meddling with what it is
that scientists meteorologists are
telling us about the storm there's
nothing remotely surprising about this
path the White House's fingerprints are
all over this Wilbur Ross his
fingerprints are all over this and I
mean it's like I'm so desensitized to it
I don't think there will be any
consequences to this I think it's the
same type of political pressure that
we've been seeing from political
interests associated with Donald Trump
and sometimes it's business interests
not in this case I guess against the
interests
just telling people what does the
science say about any number of
different things yeah and there's calls
now for Wilbur Ross to be fired good
luck with that because the person who
would fire him would be Donald Trump
yeah and of course Wilbur Ross was just
carrying out the orders of Trump or at
least if it wasn't orders it was highly
suggested that Trump would want to see
him do this indeed so if there is any
repercussion it would have to come by
way of something maybe criminal or you
know maybe like the House or Senate
looking into it not a good luck with
that getting any results too so yeah
there's there's not gonna be any
repercussions for this and there should
be because this is a dangerous thing if
you're telling people that they're about
to get hit with a hurricane that's going
to ensue some panic people may try to
leave the state that they're in there
are reports of people canceling
surgeries showing up to the coastline
making sure that elderly sickly people
were we're not there and trying to get
them away so yes this isn't just like it
it all seems very funny right
Trump drawing and Sharpie a part of the
map which wasn't supposed to get hit by
the hurricane and you know the late
night hosts where we're making you know
some fodder out of it but this is
there's a serious aspect to this and it
could have been a lot worse and it was
totally preventable yeah and what you
know when I think at some point Trump
will be gone it could be in a year and a
half it could be in five and a half
years we don't yet know although
hopefully it will be sooner than later
one of my really big concerns is that
even though a significant portion of the
population recognizes the cartoonish and
ridiculous nature of a lot of what's
going on
sometimes the status quo remains the
status quo for a reason and the brazen
nature with which this administration
has taken this you know alternate I call
it the alternative facts attitude where
it doesn't matter if it's science versus
random political people saying things it
doesn't matter what the the particulars
are they are completely brazen in their
insistence on just telling their story
no matter how ridiculous it is no matter
how it contradicts everything that is
empirically known and it scares me that
that may become normalized even beyond
Donald Trump once he's gone well there's
a glimmer of hope we are seeing a little
dip in Donald Trump's approval ratings I
would imagine that
may have to do with the economy we you
know this this evidence to suggest that
we're heading towards the recession
there's of course the trade war stuff
which people aren't happy about but
maybe that dip in his approval numbers
also as a result of stuff like this that
people understand that the president is
lying to them and that that could have
dangerous ramifications and that we just
deserve better I mean maybe maybe that's
just me looking on the bright side a
little bit too much because he's done
plenty of things like this in the past
and doesn't seem to move his approval
numbers then yeah and again even though
you're right that it's been dipping the
approval range is still the same it's
sort of like 36 to 44 is the range when
things are going less well he's around
36 when things are going batteries
around 44 and because half the country
doesn't vote and because of the
electoral college system that we have 36
is still more than enough for Donald
Trump to be reelected president of the
United States which is scary but when
you do the math you very quickly figure
out that that's the reality I hope you
will join me tonight for a live stream
of the third Democratic presidential
debate on twitch at twitch TV slash
David Pakman I don't know if it'll get
shut down or not I'm going to try it I
hope you will join me and I will see you
then or otherwise tomorrow on the Friday
show the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]